in order to be a great decision maker
you have to do two things and you have
to do them pretty
intentionally you have to understand and
see the luck
you can't control the luck because luck
by definition is outside of your control
but you want to see it as accurately as
possible here here's the spread of
outcomes that can occur
and here's how likely those things are
to happen but then the other thing you
need to do is start really examining
what are the beliefs that you have that
inform the decisions that you make
many of our listeners will be familiar
with you but for those who aren't can
you give us a bit of background
what makes you an authority on decision
making
oh my god that sounds so very serious
um well i guess it's i i guess it would
be kind of the
the very strange path that i took uh as
an adult
um so i started off
after college uh in a phd program at the
university of pennsylvania i was
studying
cognitive psychology cognitive science
in particular i was really thinking
about how people learn um
so i was i was gonna go off and become a
professor
as one would after getting that degree
um and as i was
uh abd as we call it but before i um
defended my thesis i actually got sick
and
ended up needing to take about a year
off before i went out
to become a professor and in the year
that i took off i started playing poker
and i did that kind of in the meantime
in order to
support myself until i could go and
start my career
and so the mean time turned into like 18
years
as it does um i kind of kept playing
poker
um and you know and then about
eight years into my poker career i
actually started thinking about this
very interesting conversation that
cognitive science my background in
cognitive science
could have with the real world decision
making problem that poker
presents which is obviously very high
stakes lots of skin in the game
if you're bad at deciding you lose all
your money
over the long run um and so you really
have to be kind of thinking about
in particular how do people learn in
these very noisy environments meaning
um uh where there's lots and lots of
luck
uh in terms of influencing the outcome
and also lots of
hidden information imperfect information
which is by the way
almost any decision you've ever made in
your life including just like whether to
proceed through an intersection
um it is actually very poker like in its
decision
so um so i did so i played poker
until 2012. in 2002 i started thinking
about how these two things might
converge
started speaking on that topic quite a
bit and then in 2012 i retired from
poker
started really focusing this on this
full-time spent a lot of my time
consulting with companies on decision
strategy
giving talks writing books on the topic
and then i've also gone back to
academics and i'm back to doing some
academic research
in cognitive science so i i took a full
loop and i ended up getting back to
where
i started but it just took me a while it
took me a while to circle back
so i mean i guess i guess that's kind of
you know i guess i have some practical
some practical bona fides and some
academic bonafides maybe i don't know
trying to answer your question an
18-year hiatus or a sabbatical to just
go and be a professional gambler for a
bit is that what it
ended up yes yeah exactly
um okay so i think that that's as
credentials go
that's not bad you've got the the
academic
underpinnings and you've got a world
series of poker bracelet and a bunch of
other accolades so
um talking about decisions how do we
define
a decision what is a decision
oh that's a really interesting question
um
uh yeah so so a decision
is just a choice about what your uh what
path you're going to take
so at any moment in time they're
actually infinite paths although we're
not considering all of them
um but at any given time
you can go down run one road or another
um and i'm talking obviously a
figurative
road sometimes it's an actual road um
but it's a figurative road if we think
about uh at any moment in time
you can think about the future as
branching right so there's all sorts of
features that could unfold
um and when you make a decision you're
choosing which of those possible futures
will be available to you
basically so um you can think about it
like
uh um if i'm thinking about where i want
to end up in 10 minutes
um if i go east there's a certain number
of possibilities for where i could end
up
and if i go west there's other
possibilities for where
i could end up um the other thing i want
to just say is like
a decision is not just an action that
you could commit
commit so let me go back to the root um
analogy if you're on a road i think that
we sort of think that a decision would
be
to exit the road to go off the road
but um again at any moment we could
think about
you there's there's the exit choice but
there's also the choice to stay
on the road so uh staying on the path
that you're already in is also a
decision
and and i just think that that's really
important because i think that people
think about
decisions as actively changing something
but when you don't change anything
you're deciding also not to do that
i hope that that was a clear enough
explanation i don't know i like it yeah
the difference between commission and
omission
in terms of whether you decide to enact
change i suppose as well
a decision to do one thing is as much
choosing to take that route as it is not
choosing to take
every other route that's available yeah
actually uh
so that that's really important point
um so it that's the point of if i go
left there are certain
futures that are now available to me but
the other futures the ones where i want
right are no longer
would not be available to me at least
not in the near term
so that's why when we're thinking about
a decision we're choosing the futures
that are available to us and we're sort
of eliminating
other futures that might be available to
us and interestingly enough like
once you're sort of thinking about
decisions that way it act unlocks a
really
important decision principle which has
to do with this idea of optionality
because that's what you're talking about
right
if if i choose options um i may be
uh making it so that i i am rejecting
other options that are available to me
and there are costs associated with that
and so once you sort of figure that
thing out then
what you realize is that you can uh put
sort of prioritize what the value of
optionality is and you can get
optionality because of one of two things
one is that when you choose the path
that you're on that it's quite
easy to get off that path and go back
and pick up other futures that you might
have
rejected so if i'm on a road and i exit
it's easy for me to get back onto
other roads right so that that would be
one thing so um
the difference would be like uh renting
versus buying a house
right so uh if you rent a house you have
more optionality because it's easier
to quit it's easier to get out of the
house it's easier to move
there's lower costs associated with the
decision
but if i buy a house i'm making kind of
a longer term commitment where
i've reduced my optionality and if you
were thinking about an investment
you have liquid investments in illiquid
investments right so
uh there's certain like i could buy a
stock and then i could literally sell it
the next day
but if i invest in a company as an angel
investors can be very hard for me to
divest of that
position right so that would be sort of
thinking about that piece of it
um and we want to you know it's it's
easier and we can make decisions faster
when we have when we preserve that
optionality
the other way to preserve optionality is
if we can do more than one thing at once
so
sometimes we don't have to choose to go
left or right or east or west
sometimes we could do both we could go
east and west at the exact same time
and that also helps us as well because
we don't have to reject as many options
so
like the simplest example of that is
that most people who own stocks don't
own just one
so i don't have to choose like oh
there's so many stocks to choose among
i'm going to choose google and i can
only put my eggs into that basket
instead i can i can have lots and lots
of stocks at the same time
um we can also think about like dating
versus marrying again right so dating
is like i can date lots and lots of
people at once um
and for most people not all marrying
means
one person right so um i have less
optionality if i marry than if i date
because i can date in parallel
so uh so i think it's really important
as you start to sort of construct what a
good decision process is to keep in mind
what
exactly what you said that you're not
just choosing the thing that you're
choosing you're also rejecting the other
choices that are available to you
so if you can construct a decision where
you don't have to reject as many of
those things
um then you're gonna you'd generally be
better off
and not just the immediate rejection of
whatever the options are but the second
and third and fourth order effects
of going down that particular path right
a
friend of the show george mcgill who's
been on a number of times talking about
mental models and he created his own
razor
and mcgill's razor is when faced with
two equal choices
choose the one which permits the most
look and i think that you could probably
trade the word look there for
optionality
so as you go down that particular path
there are fewer options closed to you
than would have been had you have taken
the other one um
i think that's a really good razor um
annie duke said it first george there
you go mate shout out
well it's because it's really it's
really true
and the reason the reason that you want
to do that is that
when you're deciding under uncertainty
which is pretty much all the time
um even even if you have
perfect information so i'm assuming
perfect information which by the way
you never have um there's still
a variety of ways that the world can
unfold and those worlds are going to
unfold at a particular probability
and some of those things are going to be
uh comprise the downside they're going
to be things that you're not really
happy
observing and the thing is that
um you can make amazing choices
that you know are going to work out for
you say 70 of the time that would be a
pretty incredible choice we'd want to
make that choice over and over again
but what that means is 30 of the time
there's
going to be uh something you don't like
something's gonna happen that you don't
like
so uh given that you're always exposed
to that risk
one of the ways to de-risk is to
preserve optionality to choose when you
have to pass that you're choosing say
say they're both uh 30 to not work out
that i would prioritize the one that's
30
to not work out but i can do i can do
something about it i can get off the
path i can exit
it's preserving my optionality in some
way
and that's sort of separate apart from
the fact that
i can make i can know sort of everything
i need to know right now
and i can have an understanding of given
this moment sort of
what those expected worlds are but new
information is going to reveal itself to
me later that might matter to me
right where i may want to do something
different so that's another reason that
we really want to
preserve optionality because we're not
omniscient so
even if i kind of know everything about
the state of the world today
i don't have a time machine so i ca i
can't see what the world will be
tomorrow and sometimes the things that i
find out about how the world is tomorrow
are really going to matter to me
in terms of what i'd like to choose so i
think that razor's amazing
um and i'm going to steal it cool george
we are we are uh pushing your razor out
into the world
also a mutual friend of ours morgan
housel was on uh last week
is is his book not like ridiculous look
i told everyone that was listening they
had to go and get it i referred to it
what did i say
it was um robert kiyosaki with a better
a better looking author
um the handsome the handsome rich dad
poor dad
i'll tell you something what i love is
first of all the book is so incredible
but i've seen um it's particularly good
to get morgan on video
he's hilarious man i mean you get you
get on audio it's
it you also get this across but on video
in particular you really get this
that when he starts like you can just
see like
he's so passionate and he's so
excited about what he's talking about
and
if you get to see him talk you know when
you get to see him
it's like you just see it's like a kid
in a candy store like he's so excited to
be exploring these ideas and be
expressing them
um and it's so much passion and so i
just think it's like really fun to
watch him talk about his ideas um
separate apart from the fact that his
ideas are amazing like he's incredible
at communicating these things
and really like getting to the heart of
what matters without a lot of extra
words around
it um i i would really love to
aspire to express the concepts that he
does so eloquently in in
as few words as he does i tend to be
wordier than he is but anyway everybody
should get his book the psychology of
the money of money
get it i uh i said that that was one of
the first comments i made about the book
look it's linked in the show notes below
you should have already gone back and
listened to morgan's episode which was
on last week
go and check it out it'll be available
there um i said
i really enjoy the fact that because
he's coming from a blogging background
where attention is very scarce
he's had to hold people's attention so
so sharply
and that's ported across really well
into a book that's only like 195 pages i
think of like actual writing
short short very short punchy sentences
one of the chapters is like three
quarters of a page long
and uh apparently sent it off to his
publisher and his publisher was like do
you not want to
should we should we make this a little
bit longer and he's like no no it's fine
he also said that he would mud wrestle
me
on the internet for pay-per-view money
um if that's
and i'm still proposing that to people
you know everyone has a price and
it's been a tough year for investments
this year so i mean morgan
if the particular threshold is met for
interest on
on the internet we might we might end up
mudd wrestling so that's
oh my gosh okay well i don't know i
don't know if i want to see that or you
do i need look everyone wants to see
that and it will be available for 9.97
uh for a one time per one time purchase
um there you go i'm so happy you had him
on though he
everybody needs to hear what he has to
say the third time this year
he's been on the show oh yeah well it's
it's getting pretty serious between me
and him now
yeah i guess so i know yeah you're like
you were dating now it seems like
maybe this is yeah yeah yeah it'll just
become the chris williamson morgan
household show
that's what that's that's that's my
dream that's what i really want to do
um so we've talked about sort of just
the matrix of decisions
why should i be concerned about having a
process for decision making at all
why can't i just use my gut most people
probably do
yeah that's a real well i mean the short
answer is i assume you'd like to do well
in life
with some reliability i mean look here's
the thing
like it's not so much that you can't
have a good outcome
when you use your gut of course you can
i mean in the same sense that
um i can flip a coin and call heads and
sometimes it's gonna land heads
i'm gonna win a bunch of money right uh
and that's like
i could be in a situation where i'm
offering you two to one
right so i'm losing to the bat um and i
happen to win i get your dollar
okay great you know um so
the the the issue has to do with
um how are we constructing a process
that's
actually going to accomplish the things
we wanted to accomplish which is number
one
sort of get us to whatever the best
possible judgment
is given the fact that it's subjective
so
um we can think about there's what's
objectively true of the world what would
objectively be the best judgment and
then how close are we getting to
that right and given the limits of our
knowledge
um i would call the you know the if you
can get as close as possible
to that thing you're going to do better
and generally you're just not going to
do better with your gut
why because your gut isn't actually any
kind of decision tool it's not
repeatable you can't
look back at it and say well why did my
gut make that choice
um your gut is where all the cognitive
bias
lives your gut is where all the noise
lives like all the things that frustrate
your decisions are living in your gut
basically aside from all the bacteria
and undigested food
so um so
in order to be a great decision maker
you have to do two things and you have
to do them pretty
intentionally you have to understand
and see the luck that's
going to be in the way that your
decision turns out
you can't control the luck because luck
by definition is outside of your control
but you want to see it as accurately as
possible here here's the spread
of outcomes that can occur and here's
how likely those things are
to happen okay but then the other thing
you need to do is start really examining
what are the beliefs that you have that
inform
the decisions that you make and
you need to actually pick those apart
into
uh a bunch of things number one is you
have to think about what the component
parts of any decision that you make are
which is kind of the antithesis of gut
right like gut is like
i just think i'm supposed to do this and
there's no kind of why
that follows up with it besides well
it's just my gut
right um so when you think about what
are what are the component parts what
are what are the actual motivations if i
think about a statement that i make what
must be true
of the world and how can i think about
whether those things are actually true
of the world
that's kind of the antithesis of gut
because you're actually opening that up
to a process that you're examining
so as an example if if i'm investing
um and i choose to buy a stock um by
definition
uh this was something i discussed with
michael mou with michael mobison
actually just
a few days ago but when i make it an
investment in stock i'm saying that i
think that i know something
about this company that or the stock
that the market doesn't know
so it's not acceptable to just say like
why
it looks like a good stock and i have a
nose for value right okay i don't really
know what that means
you have to say you have to pick it
apart and say what is the thing that i
think that i know
that the market doesn't know so it could
be something super simple
right i think the market is estimating
the number of widgets that they're gonna
sell
okay great so now now you're pulling
that apart notice how this is very
opposite to gut
right because i'm starting now i
actually have to forecast that thing so
you also have to express yourself
precisely
um as you're forecasting those things
that you're pulling apart that must be
true
for you to actually believe the thing
that you do that you should buy this
stock for example
um so so that's kind of like the first
thing
about what you're doing in terms of your
beliefs so you're pulling these things
apart into
their component parts you're thinking
about what are the possibilities you're
you're trying to see the luck accurately
and then because you're doing that in
all
this very explicit way you now allow
yourself a way to go check back
and to say essentially what i've done is
in this very explicit way
i've created what my forecast of the
future is
not in a vague sense if i think this
stock is going to go up
but i've forecasted what i think the
states of the world are going to be
in the future how likely those states of
the world are going to exist
such that i can now actually close that
loop and go back
and check to see how well calibrated i
am and i can now do that because this is
all very explicit
that's the problem with your gut is that
it's by definition
implicit it's by definition sort of
intuitive
so i don't have that way first of all to
uh think about the decision process in
in any kind of rigorous way as i'm
making it
but worse yet i have no way to go back
and close the feedback loop into
in order to create a really good
learning loop because i can't really go
back and check
i can't say well here are the here are
my assumptions here are the things that
i thought would be true of the world
here was my forecast of the states of
the world
that were going to exist here's the data
that i was using in order to inform
that decision and so i i think that when
you're
deciding with your gut you're it's like
the the thing i say is it's kind of like
playing pink pin the tail on the donkey
right it's like that old children's
games like you just put a blindfold on
and you're sort of like and then
sometimes you actually get it right
there and you're like look how smart i
am and it's like
but that's not really a process
repeatability is one of the important
things that we need for a decision tool
what else do we need to make a decision
tool effective
um so repeatability meaning if i
use this process in the same way over
time i should expect to get similar
results
um i also need it to be something that
can be examined
right so i can examine it like an object
and understand whether i'm actually
using it in the appropriate way
um i need to be able to uh
give the process to somebody else
such that they could actually apply that
same process now we can start to see a
problem with the gut
right is i can't be like ew here's my
good
right well i guess in star wars they he
they open that animal
sleep inside of it they're always
sleeping inside of guts and star wars
um i don't know if that helps them with
and make decisions but it keeps them
alive
um but anyway so i can't i can't just
say to you like
the problem is if you say to me like how
do you make that decision and i say oh
well
i had gut feel like i just felt like
that was the right thing this is
completely unhelpful to you
um because that doesn't mean that you
can do it right so i need to also be
able to
give it to somebody else and explain how
you would use this process such that
they could also use it in the same way
that is not to say that they will get
the same results
from it because um they're issues of
talent right i mean two people can learn
how to hit a tennis ball and one person
will be much better because people just
sort of
are better at some things than others
but i should be able to get you part of
the way there i can get you to hit a
ball
right um and hopefully i can get you to
hit a pretty good ball if it's a really
good process i should get more fidelity
out of what
you're doing so repeatability i have to
be able to examine it
um so that i can understand what its use
is what its purpose is
i have to be able to teach it to
somebody else
that's really important um and then i
have to be able to go
back i have to loop back to see i have
to be it has there has to be
accountability i have to be able to loop
back to see
whether it produced it i actually
applied it well
um did i use the right tool for the
right job
that kind of thing so uh it's it's very
simple it's like a really good decision
process which has a whole bunch of
decision tools in it
it's really like just using tools right
so
i want to know uh we can think about
like a screwdriver right
okay i can look at it i can figure out
what its purpose is
right i can for the purpose that i use
it for to screw screws in the wall i can
repeat that with fidelity over and over
again
um i could hand you the screwdriver and
i could teach you how to use it
such that you could put screws in the
wall as well and then i can go back and
i can check your work
and i can see oh wait it seems to me
that you stripped the
the threads on this did you use a hammer
well i mean a hammer is the ultimate
tool as everyone knows there's no job
that can't be fixed with a hammer
which would be the ultimate decision
tool yeah yes
well yeah actually i was going to say
like breaking asphalt but you could do
it it would just be really tiring
because you could use the claw part that
would just take you a very long time but
you could actually do it
but yes underrated tool as far as i'm
concerned you could use a hammer
right so so you can think about gut as
like
what if you came in and you saw a screw
within the wall and you
said to me how'd you get in the wall and
i was like it just happened
because i'm really good at putting
screws in the wall
like i mean think about how bad that is
first of all you can't do it
second of all i can't actually figure
out like was that the best way to do it
was there a better way to do it
because i just left it in a black box
right so
and one of the things i want to be
really clear about is that uh
there are lots of decisions you're gonna
make in your life where you are actually
using your gut
just because we you know you're not
going to take a really long time on
every single decision that you make
the issue is first of all you have to
know what a good decision process looks
like
so you can understand when it's okay to
kind of go with your gut um
because there's just less risk to sort
of not having a high fidelity
process um and then the second thing
that that's just really kind of
important about that is that you have to
have a way
even with your gut decision to go back
and say well
there were things that were implicit in
my gut decision
that for me to make that decision i had
to believe were true
so let me go back and actually think
about that now
right let me think about what were the
things that had that i had to believe
were true
were those things actually true was i
missing anything what was am i
incorporating into my gut
feel about it um so that the next time i
make a gut decision having gone through
that examination one would assume i
would have honed it better
so i look there's lots of things that
you're just going to kind of go fast on
and that's okay as long as you
understand what a really good process
looks like
and you understand how incredibly
important it is to make the implicit
explicit
in your decision process so that when
you go and take a look back on
really what is the quality of the
decision that mike got produced
that you have a way to actually answer
that question such that you could tweak
and hone
and realize you know and then sometimes
you'll realize
um for say the market that i was in
uh my gut feel was pretty good but
there's something that's changed about
the market that i didn't notice and now
i actually have to go back to being
pretty deliberate
you know i i actually think about it
like like this so that you can see these
videos
so um when you're riding a bike
we know that when you turn the handles
to the right
the bike goes to the right when you turn
the handles to the left
the bike goes to the left so when we're
starting to learn how to ride a bike
it's a very deliberative process right
we're trying to figure out like how do
we balance the bike how do we keep it
upright if we turn this way are we going
to turn and you've seen people they're
sort of
you know wobbling and whatever and then
eventually we become really good at
riding bikes and it's pretty much
something that we're not thinking about
very much
right like i i just sort of get on a
bike and i go and
um not really deliberating about it so
that would be like a
it's turned into a gut decision and it
works really well
but um the world changes
so what happens when someone hands you a
bike where now
when you turn the handles it goes to the
right it goes left
and what you can see is that people fall
down a lot again
because their gut is telling them when
they want to go right to actually turn
the bars right
and now they have to sort of re-figure
out well hold on this is like a
different type of bike and so i have to
now learn this process and it takes a
while
but then once they learn it they can go
back to sort of
go you know using their gut decisions
and gut decision making are just like a
lot like that
that your gut can get you pretty far but
you always have to be sort of checking
back
in to see if the world is handing you a
bike where the handles
bars work differently right um because
that happens all the time environments
change
and and markets change so that's like
things
external to you um changing but then the
other thing is that
uh sometimes it turns out that there's a
better way to ride the bike
and the way that you were doing it
worked pretty good
right like you were winning to it
uh you were getting to where you wanted
to go it was all kind of fine
but someone shows you something that you
could do that's even better than that
would actually help you to be more
efficient or or whatever it is and you
so that's why you actually another
reason why you want to be examining your
gut
is even if nothing has changed about the
world
you may not have the best strategy the
big danger
is you have a strategy that's winning
that's like the biggest danger that you
can ever be in why
because it means you're very unlikely to
go explore if there's a way to win more
and you know you by the way uh
you can see this in investing there are
people who are winning and investing
and you they haven't answered the
question is okay you're winning that's
fine
would you be winning more if you were
indexing
yes morgan morgan says yes yes
dollar price average into the market
index funds leave it for 50 years
millionaire that's what that's what
morgan says
right so and but that's not true of
everyone but what happens is that we get
focused on the fact that we're winning
so we're doing better than zero so i'm
making four percent with my active
you know i'm sitting here on robin hood
the worst thing that happens is you're
making four percent on robin hood
that's that is that is the worst
situation to be in it's so interesting
to hear this
um this same sort of reflection
come about in multiple different areas
of human nature right so let's think
about the system one versus system two
thinking or the fast and slow from
daniel kahneman the explore versus
exploit that james clear talks about in
atomic habits when you're doing habit
setting
uh taylor taylor pearson's consciously
designed life versus execution designed
life which is
sitting back thinking very very
deliberately and having to pay the entry
price that is
being super super conscious about every
little area that you do
and then the hope is that over time that
becomes
absorbed into your mode of being and
because you can perhaps when you when
you're a child it's really really
important that you don't put your hand
on the hot stove
as you get a bit older that decision
still has the same
level of consequence if you get it wrong
but the chance that you get it wrong
is significantly lower so you don't have
to be conscious about it but you do when
you're a kid the same as
the reason why they've got those little
foam cups on the edge of all of the
sharp
tables that are at eye height for
children in houses because they might
run around and not see a table and then
lose an eye
when you're older as an adult that's
usually not the concern you have despite
the fact the consequences are the same
so this is how we expand our domain of
competence by being deliberate by
learning by probably making some
mistakes hopefully not losing an eye
and then we allow ourselves to move on
to whatever comes next
what do you think most people presume
wrongly about good decision-making
uh that a good decision will get you a
good result
and that a bad decision will get you a
bad result so this is the difference the
main thing that people get wrong
this is the difference between being
right and being accurate right
yeah exactly so um
mostly if you have enough cracks
at it good decisions will actually get
you good results but that's in the
aggregate
so in the aggregate that that is true
um that uh assuming that
you have managed your risk of ruin well
so that you still have something to bet
um whether it's an eye or money
um making repeated you know
repeatedly making winning decisions you
will actually end up
winning that's true in the aggregate but
what people
think is that that's true in the short
run as well
um and i think that's that's really like
the biggest mistake that people make
so what ends up happening is that uh
essentially we over index on the outcome
this is just resulting
um in order to sort of try to work
backwards what does that mean just
take us through over index on the
outcome that's resulting what's that
mean
okay so um let's
i'll so let's say that i
traveled through an intersection safely
um did not get in an accident nothing
remarkable happened
what people will say is that that must
mean that i made good decisions as i
went through the
intersection and if i travel through the
intersection i get in an
accident they'll say i must have made
poor decisions this is true like
um uh i make an investment and it loses
i made a mistake i make an investment
and wins i must be a genius
um i ordered the chicken instead of the
fish in the restaurant and it's gross i
made a mistake
i ordered the chicken instead of the
fish and it's amazing i knew it
right like obviously great decision
um so that's resulting it's basically
saying if i know what the quality the
outcome is that this tells me something
about the underlying decision
process um the issue of course is that i
might have gone through a red light
when i got through safely and i hardly
think now that i've told you those
details
that you would consider me a good
decision maker in that case um
i may have gone through a green light
and a car came
from the other direction and you know
what could i do um
and that doesn't really make me a bad
decision maker that it happened to turn
out
poorly um obviously same things with vet
investments i mean the
the whole thing obviously is that
there's volatility so
you can make a perfectly sound
investment um
when you're thinking about in terms of
just expected value so what's my
expectation in terms of whether
i'm going to win more often than i lose
and if you keep making choices where
you're going to win more often than
you're
you lose you're probably making pretty
good decisions
but you can lose like on in the short
run i can make an investment i can lose
and it just turns out really poorly so
uh so i think that this is the biggest
thing that kind of like really
frustrates our ability to learn
because the only thing that we can learn
from is experience
that's it that's that's what we have
aside from you know
sort of what the build built-in software
is that we come with
um we've got to learn uh about the world
as the world kind of tells us like you
know here's some data
and then we sort of process the data and
we figure this out and we're trying to
close these feedback loops and we're
trying to learn
and what ends up happening of course is
that
well we're pretty poor at learning
because we aren't aggregators we just
naturally don't sort of wait around
until we have enough data to understand
something that's significant about
the set of outcomes that we might be
observing and instead we
process those outcomes in sequence
and we don't really know what we're
supposed to take from the outcome and in
general
we just kind of take really bad lessons
from it and
it's a really strong cognitive illusion
so
in thinking of bets you know i talk
about the pete carroll example and the
super bowl
he makes a pass at the end
mathematically a really good play
um it he loses the super bowl because he
chooses this this particular
play to call and people still today talk
about it as a mistake
um likewise um you know i think
people are pretty familiar with
america's 2016 election
um and hillary clinton losing that
election
so uh again to show you like how
widespread this is and how much it
really frustrates our decision-making
and learning and the lessons that we
learn
there's general consensus that
hillary clinton made a really huge error
like really
bungled her election strategy her
campaign strategy
um and it was the error that everybody
seems to agree upon
is that she did not uh campaign in
the rust belt which is really kind of
combined of we're talking about three
states
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania
interestingly enough
ohio is one of those states that doesn't
get mentioned
as one of the states that she bungled uh
even though it's part of that rust belt
and i think the reason why is that she
she would lost that state by a lot so
there would have been no reason for her
to go
and actually campaign there but so she
loses michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania razor thin
margin across the three states it's a
total of like 80 000-ish votes
okay so um
so everybody starts writing pieces
about her terrible rust belt strategy
and how she really screwed it up and
what a mistake she made and how she
bungled that part of the us
and uh and this was horrible what her
strategy was
so here's how we can understand
where our ability to understand what a
good decision and a bad decision is
really goes wrong because what people
are saying she made very poor decisions
but here's the thing about presidential
elections it's true about any national
election it's true whether you're in
britain or germany or france or
america or wherever is that everybody
has something to say about it
well it's happening that's whether it's
a seasoned political strategist a pundit
people come crawling out of silicon
valley who are like data analysts to
write a billion pieces
on medium um so everybody's got
something to say
so i think that we should assume that
given the data that was available at the
time
that if this was a really huge mistake
there would have been lots of people
writing about it
because we have to remember that's that
idea of like what do we know at the time
that we decide right and our knowledge
is always
limited in some way we don't have
perfect knowledge we certainly can't
foresee the future
and there's just a whole bunch of stuff
we don't know um so
we have to judge decisions based on the
knowledge that's available at the time
that somebody makes the decision
and i would agree it would be a huge
mistake if there were a lot of people
who were yelling and screaming
about michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania and the fact that
it seemed like even though the poll said
that she was way ahead there
and running even in places like florida
and new hampshire
and ivanishin like arizona which is
where she was spending her time that
maybe she should skedaddle out of
florida and get to these three states
there if there were lots of people
saying that
and she did not know that herself i
would agree she was not using the
information that was available to her
but you can look it up on google for
yourself there are crickets
now you do start to see tons and tons
and tons of articles about this
particular issue but the first one of
them appears on november 9th
which is the day after the election
how fortunate yeah there were by the way
two really big long articles about i
think was pennsylvania in particular
and they were critiques of trump
post talking like that to me
reminds me a lot of when i watch my
housemate play cod
so i've i've got into during the
pandemic i've really really gotten into
watching him play warzone
online terribly he's awful toby
you i love you man but you suck okay god
you know if this is not only does he
suck in
terms of how i get to see the uh more
subjective areas of his game like when
he crouches and when he sprints
but there's objective measures as well
in that he sometimes goes through a
whole game with zero damage being made
et cetera et cetera but i'll sit there i
know it's uh you could just pull the
trigger for the whole game i'd probably
don't even know the game and i know that
has to be about it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing
um but i'll happily sit there and abuse
the guy with no control of myself just
with like a chocolate bar or like a
glass of water in my hand
and i'll happily abuse him and tell him
that no no you should have gone left oh
why didn't you go left like i knew that
left was a good
but i don't i only ever say that like
after he's dead and on the floor
or like doing a signal thing where he
needs someone to come and revive him
so it's it's precisely the same as this
right and everyone's everyone's a critic
everyone's uncle exactly it's like
and this is why i say it's a real it's a
it's a really
robust cognitive illusion
um in the same way that when i look at a
visual illusion
you can explain to me what the illusion
is but i cannot unsee it
right like you can see like on twitter
you'll see like all these great
illusions like it'll be a stationary
cube and because the background is
flashing you'll see the cube spinning
is that steve stewart's thingy that you
follow
well so he yeah so he'll post them phil
top ted luck we'll post them there's a
japanese person
who posts tons and tons of visuals steve
steve reposts his stuff doesn't he
yeah exactly i'll repost them sometimes
phil tatlock has been reposting a lot of
them
lately so the thing is you can explain
to me what's happening right you can say
to me
the cubes are not moving it's the fact
that the background is flashing that's
making you see the cube spin
and you can and i'll go that's really
interesting and then i look at it and
the cubes are spinning yeah
um and this issue of resulting is like
that
so um i know
what i know that nobody was talking
about this before november 9th
i know that and it's very hard for me
not to feel
deep down inside of me that hillary
clinton made a mistake
it's hard for me to get over that um
because it really does feel that way
like
god when that that food comes to you in
the restaurant and it's disgusting
so so that's kind of the first thing
that has to do with like this over
indexing on outcomes but the other thing
that comes from that is also
that we misremember what our state of
knowledge was at the time
so that's what you're talking about with
i knew you should have gone the other
way
right so there's a little bit of a
difference between um
uh you know somebody saying it was the
wrong choice for you to go right
as if that has now revealed itself to
them afterwards
versus saying i knew beforehand
that you should have gone the other way
regardless of whether you said it or not
um this actually happened to me with
this hillary clinton thing because i
pitched it to somebody at a major
newspaper
and they said oh i can't run this
because i did actually know this
and i had a bunch of friends who knew
and we're all talking about it and
reading about it
and i'm thinking you're at a major
newspaper you could have literally
published that
but you did not so i'm not exactly sure
why you kept that incredibly contraring
opinion that
that may have gone viral to yourself
it's so
you apparently did but but literally
they're misremembering
what their state of knowledge is so now
think about how hard it is when we talk
about like
we were talking about what makes a good
decision process and part of it is this
ability to go back and examine
if you can't even remember what you
thought at the time if you can't
remember what your state of knowledge
was
when you made the decision how on earth
are you going to create any fidelity
around that process like how are you
going to go back
and then what are the lessons we're
learning so i'm seeing it in the united
states right now where people
everybody like you can everybody's
talking about like
oh yeah you know biden's running ahead
in these three states but i'm sure it's
wrong
that you know because obviously there
was a polling error in those three
states
the thing about a polling error is you
can't find out until after the fact so
now everybody has decided that we all
knew this and
you know now the only strategy that you
could possibly apply to a presidential
election
would be to spend all your time in
pennsylvania and wisconsin wisconsin and
michigan apparently
what a terrible lesson to take from that
the lesson should actually be
is there a way for you to detect which
polls are more accurate and which
aren't and if they're not accurate can
you predict
which way they might not be accurate
because there's no
reason in this election cycle that we
should assume if there's a polling error
that it would go in trump's favor versus
biden's favor right it can go that that
can actually go
both ways and we know that this is
actually quite hard because
in 2016 the polls nationally were dead
on
and in states like florida and new
hampshire they were also dead on
right so we had this very specific
polling error i would actually argue
that in this election cycle is probably
more likely and i don't know i'm just
making this i would have talked to a
pollster because there may be just um
structural problems to pull in those
states
but assuming there aren't structural
problems i would assume that they would
be pulling more accurately
because i have to imagine the pollsters
are like
super duper like holy crap i can't get
these three states wrong
and so if there were a polling error my
guess is if i were to bet given my
knowledge i would want to go find out
more before i place money on it but
if i had to bet i would say the polling
error would be more likely to occur
outside of those three states
right now just because i have to assume
that people are really kind of looking
at those
that's assuming there's not something
structural about those states that would
make polling them quite hard
but you can see that people are kind of
taking the wrong lesson so you can have
a candidate now come along
and just sort of based on this idea that
she made a horrible mistake say
my campaign strategy should be to really
campaign hard in those three states but
that could be completely a terrible
campaign strategy
you're just learning really bad lessons
i don't envy the job of a campaign
manager
at all yeah it's just no you're just
gonna like if you win you're a genius if
you lose you're an idiot there you go
it's it's so so hard how can people
spend their decision-making time more
wisely
you talk about this in the book and i'm
very very very interested
in the opportunity cost of not making
decisions of how long it takes to make
one
obviously it's all well and good as
saying here be conscious with your
decision-making process and let's have a
this that and the other but you need to
spend that time as wisely as possible
right
yeah so so we've hinted at it a little
bit because we've been talking about
like
what road are you on and are you getting
off the road and that kind of thing
which is a little bit of unlocking it so
the idea is look you wanna you wanna
obviously
understand what a really robust decision
process looks like
um but then i said sometimes you're
gonna go really fast
i would not want someone to think that
you should never go fast the question is
what are you going fast on and what are
you going slow on how are you valuing
the time
that you're taking in order to make the
decision because every minute that you
spend
gathering information and considering
options and try to kind of
map these things out is a minute that
you can't get back
so what we want to generally be thinking
about
is how can we be sort of maximizing the
amount of time that we're spending on
things that are going to
bear fruit and minimize the amount of
time that we're spending on things that
aren't going to be particularly fruitful
and that includes your decision-making
time so you want to
spend your decision-making time on
places where there's really going to be
a lot of value to doing so
and not spend so much time on places
where there isn't going to be a lot of
value to doing so and actually sometimes
um you're costing yourself a lot by
um not going super fast and there's two
ways that you can cost yourself a lot by
not going super fast one is that options
expire
so sometimes by going slow the
opportunity actually goes away
um so actually that was a really big
problem with coronavirus response
was that options kept expiring um
so a simple option for example uh would
be
um uh
make sure when you get the very first
intelligence
that there's something bad a brewing um
that you ramp up production of ppe
right so uh the longer you wait to do
that
uh the option to actually have that be a
reasonable solution
to mitigating the risk of the virus kind
of goes away
because obviously as soon as you have
like widespread community spread
it's helpful but then you're trying to
sort of roll back a disaster as opposed
to prevent a disaster so that that's an
example of like the opportunity
going away obviously if you're thinking
about investing in a company at some
point they close the round
so so there's that cost to it but the
other the other cost
can be that sometimes the thing that you
really need to know
or that you want to know is um
how the world responds to the decision
that you made or how you respond to the
decision that you made as you're trying
to sort of gather information
um and the best way to do that is to
like to do a lot of stuff really quickly
in order to to get lots and lots of
information so that when you do have to
make really significant decisions
you have much better models of the world
and this is true like of our own
preferences you can think about this as
like
um a priori like ex-ante there are
certain things that i won't know whether
i like or not
right it could be a food that i've never
encountered before and i kind of don't
know xanthe
the only way that i can know whether i
like that food is to actually taste it
so there's no reason for me to research
it and go ask a lot of people their
opinions about the food
and so on so forth i might the best
thing i can do is just try it
um and that's true of a lot of stuff
that we can that that we want to be
doing so the question then is okay so
how do you sort of sort through that
stuff to figure out
what are the things you can go pretty
fast on and what are the things you can
go pretty
slow on or you should go pretty slow on
and the answer
basically all comes down to a core
principle which is
in cases where when you experience the
downside it's not that bad
you can go really fast because what
we're really trying to do when we make
decisions and we take our time
is to try to reduce the probability of a
bad outcome occurring
and increase the probability of a good
outcome occurring so we want to make
sure that on balance
we're winning the decision that the
upside potential is greater than the
downside potential
and the more that we can create a spread
between those two things the better off
we are
occasionally it's sort of like you're
choosing among bad
options because that does come up
sometimes you're kind of in a no-win
situation
and even then you're trying to increase
the spread between those you're trying
to figure out which one has the least
it's sort of the least bad um sometimes
you have all good options and you're
trying to
figure out which one is the most good
but all of these are just sort of
weighing upside and downside potential
so presumably what we're getting out of
sort of most
mostly what we can get out of spending
more time
is that our forecast
of what the upside and downside
potential is
gets more accurate so if we spend less
time
we're sacrificing some accuracy so we
may end up with
a little bit more downside than we would
have
if we had spent a little bit more time
that's why it all comes down to in terms
of the time that you spent
you spend how bad is the bad because if
the bad isn't that bad it doesn't really
matter you should probably just like
move fast and break things as they say
you should just go around because
what you're getting in return is you're
not missing out on opportunities
and um you're learning a lot i mean this
is a way to do this fast cycling
learning so let's sort of figure out
like okay so how do we figure out when
bad isn't bad so
we've already talked about a couple of
those things right so
one is uh when something's really
quittable
so if i'm uh thinking about a decision
that i'm making and i'm trying to decide
do i want to exit
um uh when
whenever i choose a route um
i might experience downside on that
route there could be a road closure
but also i'm giving up the gains that
are associated with other options
okay so this is one of the things that
i'm risking when
i know that i can easily get off the
road that i'm on
and go get on another road what that
means is that i'm naturally mitigating
the downside
because i can just quit when the world
starts to reveal itself that
a particular future is unfolding that i
don't find particularly favorable
or when i think that i'm going to like
durian and i taste it and it's yucky i
don't have to finish the whole
fruit i i just throw it in the trash and
go find something to wash the taste out
of my mouth
right so um so
the basically we can sort of think about
this is the more liquid the thing that
we're doing is
the faster we can go because
we can gather information and as we
gather that information if we don't like
what we're seeing we can go
we can get out and go to other options
so
that's credibility then we also already
talked about doing things in parallel
so we know that we're always exposed to
a certain amount of risk
but what we can do when we do things in
parallel is we can just basically
sort of have a bar right we can say this
is good enough i'm going to do it
because i'm going to do enough of it
that i don't really have to worry about
whether i'm going to realize the
downside on this particular choice
because across all the choices i make i
know that i'm going to be positive
expectancy
and so therefore i should make a bunch
of money
um so obviously that's just portfolio
theory right so i can own a whole bunch
of stocks and then
um that's great um
another way to think about doing things
in parallel is that uh
if i can get on both sides of a position
at the same time
um then i can obviously go faster
because i'm sort of betting on both
things at once i'm betting that i'm
right and i'm wrong
um at the exact same time so that would
be like uh
in not necessarily in every single
market but in a lot of markets stocks
and bonds would work that way
against each other recently uh
doing the night class of the career
you're considering doing whilst
staying in your current main mainstream
job to see if you like it or
moonlighting on a weekend as a
veterinary nurse whilst you continue to
do your art midweek or whatever it might
be exactly
yeah um
you can't decide between the chicken and
the fish on the menu so you ask me if
i'll order the chicken and you order the
fish
do that um so hedging would go into this
category
in general so i want to have an outdoor
wedding it's my dream
but i'm concerned that it might rain i
could
choose to have my wedding indoors
like in a banquet hall or something like
that um
but notice that i lose my optionality
then because i can't actually have it
outdoors
then but what i could do instead is i
could choose a location where i could
set up a tent
and i may never use the tent that's okay
um
because i'm thinking about that in
advance so um i'm basically paying
something for the optionality because
the optionality is worth something to me
um so i don't want my day ruined and if
the price of the tent
is tolerable to me for ensuring against
having my day be ruined i'd rather have
an indoor and outdoor wedding
essentially at the same time in a
theoretical sense
yeah right so i can i can do them both
at the theoretically at the same time
even though
only one of those things is actually
going to occur but i've allowed myself
the a future where i could do either
right so that's that's exercising
options in parallel so that
also really helps mitigate um the risk
and you can go much
faster on decisions that are liquid
um and hedgeable basically so you can
think about those two things
or where you can just straight up do two
things that you think are winning
at the exact same time so you're not
then that's not really a hedge
the other thing you can think about is
just generally there's a whole bunch of
decisions that we take a lot of time
with that actually aren't particularly
high impact
and if we could actually sort of step
back and say
on its own separate and apart from
whether there's any optionality
um is this something that's just
generally low impact and i'm just
getting hung up on it for reasons other
than
um what the impact of the bad outcome
might be or at least the long-term
impact of the bad outcome um maybe i
could actually speed up a bunch of those
decisions
so uh so an example of that is
so i i know a lot of people who do this
i may have sometimes done this myself
people really spend a lot of time like
you know back in the old days when we
went to
restaurants and dined in um
where people will spend like forever
trying to decide between two things on a
menu do you know anybody like that
yes including including some of my good
friends
yes and they're like literally they're
asking everybody like what are you
ordering what are you ordering what are
you ordering what are you ordering you
know
like okay well they're different people
they have different tastes than you do
um
and then you know they'll narrow it down
and then they're calling over the wait
staff they're being like which one do
you think is better
um uh and it's like literally they're
like taking forever on this decision
but the pro that the reason why that's
such a bad use of your time
is that first of all you could be using
that time for things that might make you
bring more enjoyment by like actually
talking to the people that you're with
that might be fun um uh but it's really
more that
that the impact of sort of like not get
being quite as accurate about which dish
you're gonna like and ending up with a
dish that maybe isn't so good
or is a little bit more likely to maybe
not be so good is so small that there's
no reason to be spending really any time
on this decision whatsoever
and the way that you can get there is
you can i talk about this thing called
the happiness test
um which is to do a little time
traveling to try to figure out what the
impact
of the decision is so um if i see you
if you order something and you eat it
and it's terrible i guess we do take out
right now
and you get it's like gross and it's
like yucky and you end up throwing it
out
um and i see you a year after this
happens
and i just say to you hey do you
remember a year ago when we ordered
takeout and the dish you got was like
gross
um and i just say how much of an effect
did that have on your happiness today
almost any almost none unless it unless
it was that dish i had that had
salmonella in just after i came back
from africa
last year which that that did have a
fairly long lasting impact
yes so apart from food poisoning but
food poisoning
is um all things being equal because if
you're at a restaurant where you might
get food poisoning that's going to be
true of every single dish that you get
um so so i agree separate apart from
food poisoning
um so what if i catch you in a month
you didn't get food poisoning i was just
yucky don't i can't even remember it
right what about a week are you still
like a week later are you like i'm so
sad my week was ruined because i had a
bad takeout dish
probably not probably so
basically what you can get out with the
happiness test and i use happiness as
like a proxy
for um in general like are you reaching
your goals
right um is that what you're what you
can see
is what is the long-term impact of sort
of observing
the bad result right like if i actually
observe the future in which the dish is
gross
or i don't like what i watched on
television or the book was kind of bad
or the movie that i went to go see kind
of sucked
or i had a bad date or whatever it is
um the the shorter the time period in
which i can catch you and you tell me
that didn't have any effect on your
happiness the lower impact
that decision is going to be so we can
see that like if you're making a choice
about getting married
where for most people but not all but
for most people that would be
um a choice to be committed to one
person
and not have other people involved in
the equation um
that is going to have a pretty long-term
effect on your happiness
if your marriage isn't going to go what
it isn't going well it's going to matter
to you
right but if you kind of have a bad date
it's not going to have a long-term
effect on your happiness
so here we can separate out the things
that really are going to have a
long-term effect on your happiness and
the things aren't
and the things that aren't going to have
a long term on your happiness honestly
you spent
shouldn't spend too much time with and
in general
as we think about where are we going to
allocate our decision making time
what we want to be doing is thinking
about it like a menu
the like a really good approach to a
menu
is basically to sort the menu into
options that you like in options that
you don't like
and once you get to options that you
like
that are kind of in that bucket you can
generally pretty much sort of be
flipping coins among them
um and one of the good ways to kind of
clarify that for yourself like what
belongs in the bucket of things that i
like
is to apply the only option test uh
which is essentially to take anything
out of that bucket
so we can think about like a venue right
if this were the only dish i could order
would i be happy with it
and if the answer is yes you can put it
in the like bucket if the answer is no
i'd be really sad if that was the only
thing i could order you
you sorted out so your your decision
making time should be spent on the
sorting
but not on the picking you can think
about once things are sort of in this
bucket of stuff that i like
then anything in there is just picking
and you may be under the
illusion that you can separate out
whatever small differences there
are in expectation for any of those
individual options
but we're deciding under uncertainty
right like we don't have a whole bunch
of information
least of all how it's going to actually
turn out which is the thing that you
would want to know
so you're not actually probably going to
be able to sort out with any fidelity
with any accuracy what the slight
differences are between the items that
are in your okay this is a thing that i
think i'm going to win to bucket
um so stop trying like just go ahead and
flip
a coin once you've got them in a bucket
now obviously
um the more information that you have
available to you the more
the more accurately you're modeling
that that information and that data your
bucket is going to be smaller
but regardless that bucket is always
going to hold more than one option
right so the less information you have
the kind of you know if your model isn't
very exact
your bucket may be much bigger the more
information the more data
all that stuff you have that bucket
might be much narrower
but once things are in the bucket stop
trying to pretend that you can actually
split them apart really bad use of your
time
that's where you really lose
opportunities to go find other things to
get into the bucket
that's where i want to be spending my
time i want to find other things that i
can put in the bucket
i don't want to spend my time sorting
among things in the bucket i want to go
get other things into the bucket
that's where all of my time should be
spent and then you're going to have
fewer opportunities expire
when you do that and the only thing that
i would say is that once you do have
things in the bucket to your point
um one way to decide not instead of
trying to figure out like what's the
difference in expected value just say
they're both in the bucket
is there one that's more credible
can i do these two things at the same
time right you can ask those types of
questions about optionality and that
that will help you do some sorting
of the things in the bucket that may
help you actually get a higher fidelity
choice
but all things being equal once they're
in the bucket just flip a coin
i wrote a newsletter last week which is
actually about
my golden rule for decision making which
is far
far less sophisticated than the stuff
that you go through in your book
but um i found this quote i can't even
remember where it was from that said the
quality of your life depends upon the
quality of your decisions
therefore making precise decisions is is
quite important
and the rule that i came up with was or
the rule that i tend to use
which takes the third party perspective
from shane
parish from farnam street uh and a
little bit stuff from james clear
was to ask myself the question what
would me tomorrow have wanted me today
to do like you've got these two things i
want a cookie
i want to not go to the gym i want to do
whatever
um the third party perspective being
able to take that that third-party
perspective is super useful
um because it helps to give you just a
little bit more distance between the
present self which we all know
is just a total bastard and the
remembering self which is actually
really really
useful so if you were to write a couple
of golden rules
that people can take away and can help
them
to make better decisions is there stuff
that people can remember to sort of keep
in their mind
a couple of little maxims any duke's
maxims that you've got that they can
take away
yeah so well first of all let me just
say your point about the time travel
is really that's really key that's what
the happiness test is doing
right in the moment you're like oh if i
get the chicken and it's bad i'm gonna
beat myself
up thinking i made a mistake whereas
what this does is says when you're
looking back in a year you're even going
to care
and that allows you to get into a more
rational place about
about um sort of how much time you're
spending and how much worry and how much
anxiety
you have around that decision do i have
any maxims
um that will help people with their
decisions
yes okay here's one if you want to know
what somebody thinks don't tell them
what you think first
why so
one of the things that you're talking
about when you say it like the
remembering self
is that's actually you know in thinking
fast and slow obviously it's a
discussion of the inside and outside
view right
so getting to the remembering self is
actually a way to get to the outside
view in other words to get outside of
the things that are driving
the decision in the moment where you're
driven by your own perspective and your
own biases and
kind of what you want to be true of the
world um to outside of yourself by
imagining yourself as an outside
observer because that's really what
you're doing when you're thinking about
the remembering self is you're trying to
imagine how somebody else would view
this decision
from the outside so uh one of the most
valuable decision tools that we have
is to get to the outside view to think
about how how would somebody else view
this
the the problem that i'm considering um
and we know that two people with the
exact same data can come to very
different conclusions people apply
different mental models they have
different perspectives they may have
different information than you have
they could have a different fact that
would be very helpful to you
and so uh we'd like to in order to
become better decision
makers to live less in the inside view
and more in the outside view
we want to we want to be living the
outside view which i suppose is another
maxim
all right so so how do you get to the
outside view well one of the ways is to
go find out what
other people think because um
a lot of the outside view by definition
kind of lives in other people's heads
they've got a lot of the information you
don't have and they have a lot of
perspectives that you don't have that's
you know separate apart from base rates
you should go google
so one of the problems that we have is
that when we communicate to each other
um human beings really like to be
members of a tribe
and part of what creates cohesion in a
tribe
is uh that you believe the same things
to be true
uh we see this in politics um and so
human beings are kind of like agreement
machines
if you've ever been in a meeting which
i'm sure you have you'll notice that a
lot of the meeting is spent on areas
where people agree
that makes us feel good it makes us feel
like we're like on the same page and a
team player
but that's true just like
interpersonally as well right
so you know we've all been at like
cocktail parties where
someone says something that you totally
disagree with and you're like don't
speak up
it's like you don't want to be rude so
um what you always need to be thinking
about is that
your beliefs can really infect other
people
yeah so when i tell you what what i
believe to be true of the world
i am much less likely to find out what
you think is true of the world
when i tell you what i believe the best
course of action is
you are much less likely to tell me what
you think the best course of action is
not with any fidelity and the worst
thing i could do is if i'm asking you
about something that happened in the
past and i'm trying to figure out
whether i
should have turned left or right in my
video game if i tell you i died
then i've ruined the whole thing right
so
you need to hide that information from
the other person and actually
what your goal is by not telling them
all the things that you think
or you know that that are um or like the
outcome
is that i'm trying to put you into the
same state of knowledge that i was in
at the time that i made the decision
because when i tell you my belief
there's sort of
a couple of things that could happen one
thing is that you could believe a
different thing but you could think i'm
wrong
and so you don't speak up another thing
is that
um you could believe a different thing
but either
you don't want to embarrass me or you
want to move the meeting along or
you don't have enough skin in the game
to like tell me or whatever so you just
suppress it for that reason not not
because you think you're wrong you
actually think you're right
but you don't actually speak up and the
third thing that can happen is if i'm
speaking and i tell you what my opinion
is that your opinion can shift while you
hear me
and so by the time that you actually
speak up you've come to a place that
agrees with me more
even though you didn't start in that
place this is obviously particularly
problematic for people who are perceived
to be leaders or subject matter experts
so you can imagine if i were asking for
your advice on a poker hand that i
played and i told you
how i played it i said the person in
front of me
raised and i tell you all sorts of
details about the person that you would
need to know in other words the
knowledge that i had at the time
and then i said i looked down and i had
an ace queen
and so i raised him back because
i'd seen him play and i felt like uh
he was probably pretty weak because he'd
been playing a lot of hands and so i
felt like a i probably had the best hand
and b
i thought there was a good chance that
he was going to fold and so on so forth
which is really how we communicate to
people because somehow we think that
my opinion is really valuable data for
you to have
what do you think's going to happen now
if you didn't think that
if your your instinct was to call you go
i must be wrong
and now i actually don't get to hear
that opinion from you interpersonally
that's a really interesting
challenge for people to come up against
i think it's something that i learned
during the process of this show and i
brought up a couple of times with
uh communication experts that
allowing a short question to sit
during a conversation is really
uncomfortable and
i noticed when i was talking to people
that there would be this sort of
weird after effect echo thing i'd say a
question
and then and then ask a question
and have this what's this trait what's
all that what was all of this like extra
words that i needed to say at the end of
it
but i think sometimes especially if you
were speaking to someone who perhaps was
an authority
in a particular subject field or even
just someone whose opinion you respected
generally
you would ask a question and then
clarify i don't know just do something
that dampens the impact of sitting in
silence because we hate silence and if
it's silent it's because
i have nothing to say and you think i'm
boring and i'm do oh my god i better say
something
and you get it out and that totally
ruins the end result and the end result
is to try and get
this other person's point of view to
replicate the situation that you were in
so you can iterate the learning
experience so that it's replicable so
that you actually understand it and all
that stuff
right i mean you kind of think about it
this way it's like
if i could like create a map of the
things that you believe and the
perspectives that you have
and i also was able to map my own
perspectives and beliefs and knowledge
and facts and so forth
and i laid those on top of each other
there are places where
those maps would be totally overlapping
we both agree that the earth is round
yeah yes um but then there's places
where
uh where it would diverge right so you
can think about like laying your hands
on top of each other right and
you know the places where the fingers
aren't lined up perfectly would be
places where we have a
dispersion of opinion and the palms
would be places where we agree
um we live our lives trying
basically forcing more agreement than
there actually is or
like creating the illusion of lots of
agreement
and that's because when we talk to
people we
talk in a way uh we do two things one we
we speak to them in a way where
we're much less likely to hear the
dispersion in a real way to find out
that they have a different opinion than
we do
um number one and number two is we'll
also talk
uh in ways that are loose enough that
the target area is so broad
that while we could have very different
opinions it wouldn't appear so
cool sort of changeability almost right
so um you know that an
example would be well i mean the easiest
way to think about it is like uh when
you use
natural language terms to describe
probabilities so if we both say
i think that we should invest in this
stock and there's a real possibility
that we're going to win
and you say yes i agree there's a real
possibility we're going to win
we didn't actually find out what both of
us mean a real possibility is
and andrew mobison and michael mobison
um
actually did like this great survey
where they actually just had a whole
bunch of people online
like answer when i say this word like
it's a real possibility it's going to
rain tomorrow
um what probability do i actually intend
when i say that
uh and it turns out uh somewhere between
20 and 80
of the time and it's a pretty even
spread across
strangely it's so useless yeah it's like
they're totally useless words but think
about how often
you're using those kinds of useless
words right
and and that's what i said about like a
good decision process breaks things into
the component parts
right like you have to sort of think
about precisely what does it mean
if i think that i'm supposed to invest
in this stock
what are the things that i mean
um that i can sort of pull out of there
that i think the market doesn't know
that i do
the specificity is important right
specificity is really important
because i'm trying to find out maximally
where we have a dispersion of opinion
which i can't do unless i'm really
specific
so first of all i have to say what are
the things that for me to make this
investment what are the things that i
think need to be true of the world
in order to make a winning decision
right
um but so so i mean you can literally
regress on this so i i might define that
and then just ask you to tell me in very
precise
words um uh you
hopefully using some kind of precision
like a scale of zero to five
where we can see that i'm a foreigner or
two uh actually forecasting a
probability
uh if it's like i wanna know how many
widgets you think that they're gonna
produce you would give an estimate with
a lower bound and an upper bound instead
of saying a lot
or something like that right um
uh if you if you're saying like i i
really think like i know
uh i know that the unit economics aren't
great but the mock
market opportunity is huge okay but what
does that mean
how big does the market need to be in
order to balance out the unit economics
can you specify
that for me right so the more specific
that we can get so instead of saying i
think there's a real possibility
that it's going to rain what i want to
know is what probability do you actually
intend like what what what's the
probability it's going to rain and i'm
going to let you give me a lower bound
and an upper bound i don't care
because that's going to help me
understand how uncertain you are like
how much uncertainty there is in your
forecast so um so
here's how a great conversation would go
um what do you think the chances of rain
are tomorrow
in the northeast of the uk probably
about 90 percent
right so great and hopeful and i've
hopefully written down my forecast
myself what i don't want to do is say to
you
i think there's a 70 chance it's going
to rain tomorrow what do you think
i definitely don't want to do that and
worse yet i don't want to say i think
there's a real possibility it's going to
rain tomorrow
what do you think because you'll
probably just endorse that
because if it's real possibility i could
be thinking 40
and use the term real possibility and
you you think it's 70
and now you know or 90 or whatever and
now we thought we agreed when we
actually didn't
i'll tell you what so what's an
interesting thing i think it's really
important
it really is um there's an interesting
insight i had
with a an author who was looking into
how to have productive disagreements and
he talked about the danger of overusing
analogy
and that's the linguistic equivalent of
what we're talking about here
that if it's well you know
when the rubber really meets the road
with this you know as soon as you start
to abstract yourself
away from the conversation and the real
talking points
that is a very manipulative very
effective manipulative tool
and he said that a lot of the time um
people that talk in hyperbole so use
trump as an example
you know spectacular fantastic wonderful
majestic all of this sort of stuff
and when you start to create um
use these analogies you no longer can
actually pin down what someone's talking
about
you know that he's not talking about the
frog trying to cross the road like it's
not it's not about
that that's a proxy for what he's
meaning that he's talking about
um and yes it's so easy for us to tumble
down this right word
so yeah i do this with my clients all
the time where they'll say something
like that
right where well there where where
they'll say
uh i think we should do this even the
the economics are great because it's
going to
really increase the value of our
investment pipeline
and i'll say hold on a second
i don't know what that means what you
just said so
i need to and literally it's you have to
write down
how what how much of an increase in the
pipeline in expected value you have to
talk about unexpected value
you have to forecast that and then you
have to tell me how much are you losing
to the things that you don't like about
the deal and you have to do that and
then
all of your partners have to do the
right too and then now you can start to
compare
and you can start to to break it out and
say i don't care if you use this word
spectacular but i'm going to
pause and i'm going to say what does
spectacular mean right because you can
think about like
for example like a spectacular job
on hannel and coronavirus might be um
that uh you know one out of every
100 milli 100 000 people died
but somebody else could describe
spectacular as one out of every
10 000 people died i i don't know what
your spectacular
is and the problem is it's not just in
terms of us trying to have
real conversation where we can sort of
dig into this stuff in a
productive way in order to inform each
other of our opinions
it's that we always have to think about
that look back
so if you say spectacular and then i try
to call you on it later
even if you didn't mean that at the time
you get to say no
that that's what i meant by spectacular
okay but that's because
we didn't know i don't nobody really
defined the term
so of course you can as as phil tetlock
would call them weasel words right like
you can sort of weasel out of any kind
of accountability to what the forecast
is that you made
when you when you have these very broad
target areas because you can just kind
of like
move around like oh no i meant the you
know over here
which you know and i i think that we
need to not allow ourselves to do that
the second thing is that in terms of
having really productive disagreement
i think we need to stop thinking that
disagreement is bad
disagreement's amazing because
the whole thing about this problem of
incomplete information
is that i don't care what your decision
process looks like
if there is a problem with the beliefs
that are informing your decision
it doesn't matter what happens after
that
because your forecasts are going to be
off the things that you think your goals
are going to be wrong how much
any particular option is going to
advance you toward your goal or cause
you to retreat away from it that's going
to be ill-informed
what the options are that you think are
available to you are going to be
ill-informed
you know i mean this it just all falls
apart
if we don't have our beliefs in order
and
the thing about our beliefs is that like
what we know fits on the head of a pin
and what we don't know is like the size
of the freaking universe
so we better start walking around and
taking these walks through that universe
of stuff that we don't know in order to
fix this problem which is that we know
so little
and if we can just increase the accuracy
of what we believe and broaden that
knowledge just a little bit
oh my gosh are we going to be in amazing
shape
and the issue is that we do not interact
with that world in order to
maximally maximally come across
corrective information
we actually interact with that world in
order to minimally
come across corrective information and
that's a freaking disaster
that's just a disaster for our decision
making so
i need to know what you believe
and when i find out that you believe
something different than me i am like oh
thank you
and now we get to talk about it and i
think that one of the ways to get to a
place where we can have really really
productive discussions
around dispersion of opinion is to
realize first of all that you should
have gratitude that you exposed it
because that allows
you to become a better informed decision
maker and i'll circle back to that again
in a second
but the second thing is that you need to
realize that there is no reason that you
need to agree at the end of the
interchange
and i think a lot of the stress and a
lot of the avoidance of disagreement
that that we end up with is because we
believe that the goal of the
conversation to
is to agree at the end and that's
poppycock
because you have your models and i have
mine
you have your beliefs and i have mine
and isn't that wonderful because that's
what a freaking market is
a bunch of people have different beliefs
and then they trade on their beliefs and
then you sort of the market sort of
finds out what's true
and hopefully through that process and
through you observing all these people
trading on their opinions
right um that you start to get your
opinions to be a little bit more
accurate
recognizing that none of their opinions
are probably exactly right either
right so you're just trying to sort of
see everything from lots of different
sides and i don't need to end up coming
around to your side you don't need to
end up coming around
to my side because the goal for both of
us is just become better informed
i want to be informed of the rationales
for why you believe what you do
and you want to be informed of the
rationales for why i believe
what i do because only good stuff comes
from that
and there's like basically three things
that can come from that
thing number one is we both moderate our
opinions
yes we don't necessarily come all the
way to agreement but you know you you
shave a little here i shave a little
there
we maybe get to a place that's a little
more accurate um so that's one thing
that could happen
another thing that could happen is let's
say chris you're right and i'm wrong
all right i now have the opportunity
with something that's
where i need to do a 180 to do as much
of a 180 as possible
right so i may be able to reverse a
belief that i have that's actually wrong
and man should i be thankful for that
because that
that belief as painful as it is to find
out that i'm wrong in the moment
is going to inform every single decision
that i ever make again in the future
so i will trade the pain of whatever it
is to find out i'm wrong right now and
be incredibly grateful to you that we
expose that
because now all of my future decisions
are going to be better off for it
but here's the interesting thing it may
feel like when you're right and i'm
wrong that the only person is benefiting
is me
but that's not true you're getting a
tremendous amount of benefit out of the
conversation
because you have to convey
to me who believes a different thing
than you why the thing you believe
you believe so strongly and what happens
when you have to explore it in that way
that my job
i don't have to convince you my job is
to convey
why i believe what i do and that the
person that i'm talking to can say but
why
okay i get this part of it but i'm not
understanding this part of the rationale
or what does the rubber meet the road
actually mean
when you say spectacular what does that
actually mean and i'm allowed to quiz
you on that not in a way where i'm
having an
argument with you just out of curiosity
i want to really understand why you
believe what you do
the act of you having to give me a good
rationale
for the thing that you believe allows
you to believe to know your beliefs
better
because what happens is that we give
ourselves a pass we think we know things
really well
but when we're forced into a situation
where we must actually convey
like where we have to teach we we very
often find out that actually there's a
whole bunch of crap i'm not exactly sure
why i believe that
this could be even if you're true like
the example that i like to give is i
really believe the earth is round
but i can tell you that if i were having
a conversation with a flat earther
i would stink at explaining why so do i
really know it
like i know it because i believe that
all the scientists say so and i've seen
the pictures and stuff
um and it seems to me that that you know
just from a logical standpoint it would
make no sense that we could keep this
conspiracy
going for so long that the rational
thing to
believe is that the earth is round but
yet i would not be able to convey it to
someone who really believes something
different
i would have to go and google it and in
the act of googling it and sort of
figuring out like what are the
scientific experiments that tell you
this and how can you tell a photo's a
doctor and things like that
i would come away from that
understanding my belief
much much better and it's only through
that process that i get to do that
so i like i wanna i wanna expose when
somebody has a different opinion than me
because that's where all the fun stuff
happens
it is indeed it is indeed look annie
today's been really fun how to decide
simple tools for making better choices
will be linked in the show notes below
anywhere else that people should go to
check out your stuff yeah well you can
go to annieduke.com
uh there's a contact form there i love
to hear from people
who have read my stuff or heard me speak
on podcasts
or whatever actually i would say that
uh how to decide i wrote how to decide
because
of people who wrote to me um and were
asking me about thinking in bets
and through those conversations with
them i realized that
um people who read thinking in bats were
kind of
like they were craving something more
practical
you know like how how would i actually
how would actually create a good
decision process how would i do that and
that's
that's why i wrote the book was because
of conversations with people who'd heard
me or
read my stuff or whatever so i love to
hear from people um so please go to
antidote.com
please you know you can follow me on
twitter at annie duke and then the other
thing i would love for people to check
out is the alliance for decision
education which is a non-profit that i
co-founded
which is trying to take all the stuff
that like we've been talking about you
know
um from james clear to morgan housel to
phil tetlock to daniel kahneman to
you know so and so forth and say there's
all this work for adults
on how to become a better decision maker
how do you shape better habits
how are we thinking about what's true
and not true how do you think
probabilistically that we know
all are the things that are going to
create a better life for people
um but where is that in k-12 education
it's just absent so what we're trying to
do with the alliance for decision
education is to really bring
um decision education this this body of
work that you're talking about and
start to pull that down into curricula
for k-12
um so that we can start teaching kids uh
you know from the start
how to become better decision makers
because um as
you know our motto is better decisions
lead to better lives in a better society
and we really really believe that and so
i would love if people could go check
out that nonprofit
everything will be linked in the show
notes below annie thank you so much for
today it's been really fun
you